this is Jocko podcast number 155 with me
Jocko Willington on the island the dead
were piling up in the mission report the
head of the convoy wrote at 2:00 p.m. on
May 20th I went to the island of nezzie
know with commander taps cough there was
a terrible scramble people crowding and
fighting around the bags of flour dead
bodies everywhere
a hundred or more and lots of people
crawling about and crying give us bread
boss it's been two days since we've been
given anything to eat they're trying to
make us die of hunger and the cold they
told us that people had begun eating the
dead bodies that they were cooking human
flesh the scene on the island was
dreadful appalling on May 21st alone the
three health officers counted 70
additional dead bodies in five cases
they emphasized the liver the heart the
lungs and fleshy part of bodies had been
cut off on one of the bodies the head
had been torn off along the along with
the male genital organs and part of the
skin these mutilations constitute strong
evidence of cannibalistic acts in
addition they suggest the existence of
serious psychopathologies on the same
day May 21st the deportees themselves
brought us three individuals who had
been caught with blood on their hands
and holding human livers
our examination of these three
individuals did not reveal any extreme
emaciation and there's an elderly local
peasant woman who reported the things we
saw people were dying everywhere they
were killing each other there was a
guard named Costilla viniq off a young
fellow he was courting a pretty girl who
had been sent there he protected her one
day he had to be away for a while
and he told one of his comrades take
care of her but with all the people the
comrade couldn't do much people caught
the girl tied her to a tree caught off
her breasts her muscles everything they
could eat they were hungry they had to
eat when costia came back she was still
alive he tried to save her but she had
lost too much blood she died that was
the kind of thing that happened when you
went along the island you saw flesh
wrapped in rags human flesh that had
been cut and hung in the trees
and that right there is from a book
called cannibal Island by Nicolas Werth
who's written books about communism I
think his most famous is the black book
of communism and cannibal Island
specifically breaks down one of the
small individual nightmares of the
Soviet gulags but the nightmare was not
small and it certainly was not specific
it was a widespread and it was broad and
it was almost incomprehensible and very
little about it would be known or not
for one man Alexander Solzhenitsyn who
not only survived the gulags but lived
on to write incredibly detailed and very
well researched two books about the
gulags some of them were fictionalized
like a day in the life of Ivan
Denisovich and for the for the good of
the cause but most comprehensively in
his three-volume tome The Gulag
Archipelago and this series is is a
massive series and it's been cut down to
an abridged version that was actually
approved by the author himself and the
abridged version has just been
re-released in Europe with a foreword by
a man that I think repopulated a to
discuss that book and among other things
I'm sure a man that I needed to give an
introduction to the first time he was on
this podcast but now who needs no
introduction whatsoever a man by the
name of dr. Jordan B Peterson Jordan
thank you for coming back on how does it
rough beginning chuckle Jesus yeah
I remember when I started listening to
you you would say something along the
lines of that you know we are quite
capable of creating hell for ourselves
as human beings and that clearly that
situation I don't know I mean that's
that's that's hell yeah and close enough
yeah and it's it's it's created by us
it's created by us which i think is
obviously horrific and the Gulag
Archipelago you know you you talked
about that book a lot and and one of the
things that on that book hits you hard
obviously for me there's a book called
about face by by colonel david hackworth
I'm from a different world I guess that
you in many ways
the book that hit me hardest in my life
was was that book about face and it's
it's one of those things that when I
read it I started putting it together as
like things started to fit and I
remember that and I was wondering I
guess from my perspective at what point
did you read the Gulag Archipelago and
at what point did you start to say okay
there's something really really
important here for me to try and
understand well I read it back in the
1980s early I would say I'd read some
Solzhenitsyn before that I read the late
day Dave
day in the life of Ivan Denisovich when
I was about 13 or 14 and then I read the
Gulag Archipelago
in my early 20s when I was reading a lot
of psychological material too when I
started reading Jung and Freud and the
great clinicians and I was reading a
fair bit about what had happened in Nazi
Germany at the same time and also Victor
Frankel's man's search for meaning and
Solzhenitsyn's book is in some ways like
an elaborated extension of Frankle
Frankle of course described what
happened to him in the Nazi
concentration camps it's a relatively
short book and it's a great book but
Solzhenitsyn's book is it's it's much
broader and and I would say deeper and
the thing that affected me most
particularly was the psychological take
on the on the totalitarian states you
know I had been studying political
science up to that point and the
political science scientists and the
economists who I would say were under
the sway of Marxist thinking although
not nearly to the degree that they are
now were convinced that the reason that
people engaged in conflict was basically
a consequence of argumentation over
resources you know it's basically an
economic argument and I never bought
that it never made sense to me
I mean obviously there are circumstances
where that's true but it didn't seem to
be fundamentally the case like tribal
warfare isn't precisely about resources
it's maybe it's about territory or maybe
it's about identity but it never seemed
to me to be simply about resources
partly because well a resource is
something that people value but it isn't
obvious why people value what they value
and so it doesn't solve the fundamental
problem anyways when I was reading
Frankel and Solzhenitsyn I started to
more deeply understand the relationship
between the individual and the atrocity
and that's what I found most interesting
was that Frankel's claim and
Solzhenitsyn's claim as well that it was
the moral corruption of the citizenry
that allowed the totalitarian
catastrophes to occur and that that in
some sense was the responsibility of
every individual in the system who
looked the other way or who participated
actively I mean even in the gulag camps
themselves they were almost all run by
the prisoners there wasn't enough
administrative manpower to run the
prison system without the cooperation so
to speak of the prayer
so it is it is a surreal sort of hell
where you imprison yourself and
Solzhenitsyn's fundamental claim and
this was true for Frankel as well and
also for vaclav havel
who eventually became president of
Czechoslovakia or at least of the Czech
Republic I don't remember which you know
they believed that it was the individual
proclivity to accept lies that fostered
the ability of tyrants to destroy the
state and then well and that also led to
complicitous with regards to all the
absolute atrocities that were occurring
in both the Nazi state in the and in the
Soviet state and I think that's true
when I read like I read Solzhenitsyn's
books and a lot of the books I read
about Nazi Germany - not as a victim and
not as a hero but as a perpetrator you
know which I think it's really important
it's something that's really important
to do when you read history is that it's
easy to cast yourself as a victim it's
easy to cast yourself as the person who
would have been heroic in the
circumstance but it's also unbelievably
useful to understand that there's a good
chance had you been in those situations
that you wouldn't have been on the side
of the good guys
you know and that's a terrible it's
really a terrible realization but it's
it's necessary realization again just
going back to this idea of what you get
out of reading because people asked me
how because I read books all the time on
my podcast and what you just said it
struck me as something that's people
have told me I read that book before but
I didn't really get out of it what you
got out of it and when I heard you read
it I said I was saying wow how did I I
need to go reread this book and I think
one of the key things is you looked at
these books as you were not the victim
but the perpetrator one thing that when
I read books I know I read a lot of
books mostly about war for me I always
think about the the people I don't
always see myself as the person that
goes and heroically storms the beaches
and survived
every you know in a war book there's
these people that get mentioned for for
up for a half a paragraph or for two
sentences and they sometimes they don't
even have a name because you know you're
the battalion commander storming the
beach at Normandy you don't you you're
not gonna name every single person but
for some reason and maybe it's just my
experiences of being in combat when I
read about that two sentences of that
guy that that gets shot that gets killed
that gets blown up
I completely understand and relate to
that person like I don't just see it as
me being the guy that is always winning
and always doing okay and always
surviving
I feel and relate to those guys that
didn't and and part of that is just
because of my friends and I lost in
combat like those guys that they're
they're people and and I think that key
thing of of reading it and going man
every single person like when you read
about these girl you're talking about
millions of people that were tortured
I'd murdered every one of those people
key word is people every one of those
people is a person and to your point
every single one of those executioner's
every single one of those murderers is
also a person you know there's a great
book called ordinary men oh yeah we we
reviewed that on this podcast right
right and so you know it's it's it's one
of the greatest books written about what
happened in the Second World War I think
on the end of on the atrocity end
because the author does such a lovely
job of while it's a strange way of
putting it in this context but you know
it's about this police battalion that
was moved into Poland after the Germans
went through and and occupied the
country and they were there to establish
order like police do but also to
participate in the mopping up let's say
that was part and parcel of the war and
you know these were ordinary policemen
middle-class guys most of whom had been
educated and socialized before the Nazi
propaganda machine really got rolling so
they weren't like Hitler Youth types
they were ordinary men and they were
brought and they had a commander who had
made an explicit case that if they
weren't able to tolerate the conditions
in Poland that they could go home so
there was no top-down order that you had
to do this or else and then they were
you know first of all they started
rounding up while mostly Jewish people
men between 18 and 65 and then you know
they started to participate in the
entire atrocious mess and they were they
ended up many of them taking naked
pregnant women out into fields and
shooting them in the back of the head
and what the author does is outline how
that happens to you you know one step at
a time and so it's a really horrifying
book and it's a brilliant book because
there's no attempt to make the
perpetrators like some creatures that
aren't human like just pure Psychopaths
and of course in in a situation like
Nazi Germany and and in the horrors of
the communist States there was no
shortage of places for Psychopaths to
prevail but that's not really the issue
the issue is well how does an ordinary
person come to participate in a global
horror let's say and what does that mean
about being an ordinary person and then
the next question is well what does it
mean about how you should conduct your
life and one of the things that I mean I
think what happened to me when I read
all this material in the 80s was that I
became convinced that there wasn't
anything more important to do in the
aftermath of what had happened in the
20th century then to try to build people
who were responsible enough as
truth-telling courageous responsible
citizens so that the probability would
increase that if they were in a position
to make a terrible choice that they
would make the right one and I would say
this lecture tour that I'm doing which
is now extended over more than a hundred
cities is an extension of the same thing
well I think it's the same thing that
you're trying to do with your book like
we were just looking at your Mikey and
the Dragons book right and your
trying to lay out a psychological
pathway that guides people towards
responsibility and courage and truth and
all of that and that is the bulwark
against tyranny and it's actually the in
debts actually at the individual level
and we kind of know that like we know
that in the West I think that's part of
the core ethos of well certainly the of
the English common law system certainly
of the American way of looking at the
world is that each citizen is the
bulwark against tyranny and that's
actually true
it's and and that's a terrible thing to
think through because it means that you
are responsible for the integrity or
lack thereof of your state and it's it's
on you
you know and and there's something great
about that because it means that your
existence actually matters to you and to
your family and and to the broader
community in a really major way in a way
that's much more significant than you
might think and that the your proclivity
to abdicate your moral responsibility
Echo's way farther than you might
consider especially under some
circumstances you know in Solzhenitsyn
one of the things that's so amazing
about the Gulag Archipelago is his
stories not only of the absolute bloody
catastrophe of the Soviet state and his
incredibly astute documentation of the
role that the utopian political and
philosophical assumptions of Marxism
played in creating the system right it
wasn't an aberration
it was a direct logical consequence of
that collectivist viewpoint and to
document all that but also to tell
endless stories about people who were
able at least to some degree to not
become corrupted even under unbelievably
horrific conditions you know and and
that's something you also get out of
Victor Frankel's book man's search for
meaning you know on it and so the the
Gulag Archipelago is a story about
horror in some sense but it's more a
story of the triumph of the fundamental
triumph of the human spirit and perhaps
no more
perhaps most evident in the case of
Solzhenitsyn himself because he
memorized this book in some sense while
he was in the camps and then wrote it
under extreme duress afterwards and it's
an immense undertaking and it's
unbelievably emotionally intense the
entire book it's like one
you know 1,700 page scream of outrage
did you just can hardly believe that
someone can write at that white-hot
intensity for such a long period of time
and you know his book had an
unbelievable global impact I think it
sold 30 million copies and it definitely
for at least a reasonable period of time
made it completely untenable for utopian
resentful utopian intellectuals to
ethically justify their radical leftist
collectivism it just blew the slats out
from underneath any ethical credibility
that communism that that remained of the
Communist doctrine by the 1970s and that
that's a hell of a thing for someone to
manage on their own it's a pretty big
task so while you were going through
that I was thinking myself I was talking
to I still talk to military folks and I
was talking to some military leaders the
young leader so like platoon level and
company level leaders so these are guys
that are in charge of you know forty
guys or maybe 150 guys and and you know
you can have some real ethical problems
and and one of the things that I said to
this group was I said hey in your in
your platoon you've got a murderer in
your platoon you've got someone in your
platoon that as a sadist
and they were kind of looking at me
suspect you know a little bit like oh
come on now come on what are you talking
about how big is the platoon a platoon
is forty guys oh yeah yeah and he's got
someone in there like that and I was I
was actually gonna ask you how accurate
I was and then I was gonna actually say
that no matter what you say how accurate
is even if it was that even if it wasn't
one out of every
you have to act as a leader as if in
your platoon you've got one of those
guys that's the way you need to well you
look in and there's another book mmm
called The Rape of Nanking we've covered
that yeah well so one of the things that
was really horrifying about that book is
so imagine that there's maybe let's say
that there's one in a hundred just for
the sake of argument that's really got
cruel and psychopathic traits what what
do you think professionally what do you
think that number is oh I think 1% isn't
unreasonable it could be higher than
that I mean it there's gradations right
right here there's brought in a group of
40 people there's gonna be one guy in
there whose proclivity in that direction
is sufficiently strong so that you
better keep an eye on them that's for
sure and this is a group of people that
joined the military right so they're
already you know you've already gotten
you've already got a group that's ok
with with theoretically you having to
kill other people right so this is
probably you know so if it's 100 that's
likely an underestimate so I think your
estimate is perfectly reasonable and it
might be conservative what happened in
Nanking was that the most sadistic
people became the targets of imitation
and emulation and that's when things
really get out of hand
yeah right so and that's the same thing
with Emil I Massacre and and that was so
when I was talking to this group and I'm
getting and I said to him I said you're
looking at me like right now like I'm
like I don't know what I'm talking about
like I'm crazy mmm who knows about the
meal I mascar and and and you know all
of a sudden it got quiet because if you
know anything about the meal I mascar it
was a normal group of guys it was a
normal group of guys there's a normal
company of American soldiers and you
know what they'd been through some
stress mmm they've been through you know
they'd had their friends killed and it
was in Vietnam there was no one really
to react against or to take your
aggression out on because the enemy you
couldn't see him they would hide and it
was but then they turned and they
snapped and the same thing you had the
leader a guy named lieutenant Calley who
was the platoon leader who you know I'd
love for you to do a psychological
profile maybe he's one of these guys
that was kind of like it was it totally
insecure about everything right and so
he got those shoulder boards on which is
the way which is the way sultanate yeah
right right his
his experience beautiful tune leader
yeah and what it did to him and he goes
through that this boy fantastic to hear
when he talks about what he did he know
he was looking back saying oh I did this
and I did listen through this little
rampage of things that he how he acted
as a commander yeah I ate the food the
good food right in front of my guys when
they weren't gonna for I was getting the
good food and he took advantage of all
the little all the little comforts that
you got being an officer yeah what yeah
well he was trying in the in the whole
book and especially in that section
which i think is in volume 2 which i
think is the greatest of the three
volumes especially the last half of it
which is just absolutely it's it's
genius level writing unbelievably
compelling and brilliant and yeah i mean
he he said that when he was in the camps
that one of the things that he did
especially once he started to identify
people that he truly admired was to go
over his life with a fine-tooth comb and
try to try to remember everything that
he did wrong by his own estimation and
then try to set it right in some manner
and so there was a that's a repentance
and then a redemption right there's a
real there's a real fundamental like a
medieval christian undertone to all of
that but it what one of the things
that's quite interesting is that when
you talk about issues that are this
serious you're almost inevitably in a
situation where you're going to find
yourself compelled to use some kind of
quasi religious language because you end
up discussing good and evil and and
issues of redemption and issues of
repentance and issues of conscience and
and sin and all of that there isn't
language that's deep enough to get at it
otherwise and what Solzhenitsyn did was
scour his conscience and try to put
himself together partly because he was
shamed he was ashamed of himself in the
face of these extraordinarily
extraordinary people who seemed to be
able to keep their moral compass under
circumstances where no one should ever
assume that they would keep their moral
compass because certainly like I said
when I was reading this the Gulag and
and other books like that I never
assumed that if I was in those
situations that I would have been one of
the people who kept their head and were
able to with
stand the temptation to become a trustee
for example and to take things the easy
way and to lord it over the other
prisoners and to and to adopt that
position of authority you know it's like
it's like a head slave among slaves but
you know you could say well better to be
the head slave than to be the bottom
slave and well that's true in some sense
with regards to creature comfort but as
Solzhenitsyn point out points out it
might be a little bit hard on your soul
and that actually turns out to be
something of of crucial not only crucial
importance psychologically but crucial
importance sociologically and
politically because if you sacrifice
that then you warp the structure around
you which is exactly what happened in in
the establishment of these camps you
know in the the soviet union was just
one big lie what was their old joke they
pretend to pay us and we pretend to work
it's like the whole the whole book and
the whole soviet union when you when you
read about it now it seems like it's it
it seems like a bad joy it seems like a
bad movie you couldn't move with just
the way the way that stalin would do
something and in the way that that order
would come out it seems like one of
those cheesy um you know comedic movies
about these decisions that they're
making and yeah they're it's surreal
it's it's completely it's completely
insane you know at one point he's
talking about the there was a new
penalty for what they call it clipping
corn or or yeah they're basically a
twelve-year-old kid would be starving
and go into a field and clip a cure of a
corn an ear of corn yeah that happened
in the Ukraine during the dekulakization
right it was against the law to go out
after the fields were were harvested it
was against the law to go out and pick
grain off the ground to feed your family
right and the prison sentence was like a
tenner which is there a little word for
10 years so you're gonna get you you
steal a piece of corn or you pick up
corn off the ground and you're getting
10 years yeah you can't comprehend that
that is very hard to Commission that
yeah work yeah and they were they you
know he'd in the earlier parts of the
book when he starts going through the
trials that they were
people yeah it's completely crazy
Mustaine grinds carica yeah well that's
why I hate to see the kangaroo courts
emerging all over all over the West you
know and and and with the university
sort of at the forefront of that said
we're building these alternative court
systems constantly that don't follow
standard legal procedure and it's really
him we're messing with things that that
we shouldn't be messing with and yeah
the whole I mean there are there are
accounts I believe it's in the gulag of
applause after Estelle in a speech right
where people would stand up and applaud
and and they and they'd applaud until
until literally the old people were
falling over because if you were the
first person to stop applauding then you
were well it was off to the camps with
you know he absolutely outlines it so
that sounds so crazy to say and he
outlines a specific thing that happened
it is that right there these no one will
stop applauding yeah because they're
afraid they're gonna get ratted out yeah
I there but by everyone else
yeah well been manned by the people who
are in fact watching and I mean you know
what by the end by the by the collapse
of East Germany one third of the people
were in for informers for the state and
so if you had a family of six people
two of your family members were direct
government informers you know and it's
it's so it's it's creepy in some sense
and it's a very weak word to use in this
situation but okay when I was at New
York University talking to Jonathan
hight about I don't know it was about a
few months ago he just wrote that book
called the coddling of the American mind
you know and he took me into one of the
men's washrooms there and there's a
poster on the wall asking students to
turn each other in
for instances of bias or offensive
speech and they have a whole bureaucracy
that's designed to do nothing else but
adjudicate these instances of biased
speech and these posters are up on the
walls as if this is something to be
proud of you know and the same thing is
happening now in Scotland where the
Scottish police are doing exactly the
same thing they're asking citizens to
turn each other in for for hate crimes
you know on the
with that is the fundamental problem
with that and the the unsolvable problem
is well who defines hate and and and
where's where's the line drawn it's like
well anything that upsets me that you
say is hate that and then it's worse
than that it's like what happens is the
people who define hate end up being
those who are looking to take offense so
that they can find someone they can
define as a victimizer so that they can
persecute them morally and justify that
inner sadism and those are the people
who end up defining the laws and then
they mask this with the morality saying
while we're doing this to make our
society a safe place it's absolutely
it's it's absolutely dreadful and to see
that happening in the UK was just it's
just awful because I mean you know the
UK is a centre Assent the center point
of of the idea of free speech I mean a
lot of America obviously a lot of
American ideals America is a great
center of free speech but I mean it's a
variation on the English system so to
see that happening in the UK is just
it's awful and to see the police doing
this and being you know encouraged by
the politicians and and and and to see
this put forward as some sort of moral
action it's just well it's it's an echo
of this kind of catastrophe that that
we're discussing yeah so I think about
that sometimes and I also have a
tendency to look at things and let not
not be too worried about it like hey
come on you know what's really good yeah
right and that's yeah that's actually
part of my personality and part of that
comes from my old job where hey I can't
worry about these little things oh
there's some little problem going all
over there that's that's not gonna be
that's not gonna fact us it's not gonna
and you got to pay attention little bit
make sure it doesn't get out of hand but
that thing about speech and and you just
mentioned the the kulak satires 2lakhs
yeah yeah they were the Ukrainian they
were the Ukrainian farmers who were good
at farming when I read this part it got
me worried about my own personal laksa
days ago attitude towards things that I
think all that's not big of a deal let
me let me read this little section about
the about
the escalation of the word kulak yeah
and and where it started and where that
yeah that's good that so here we go in
Russian a Kulak is a miserly dishonest
rural trader who grows rich not by his
own labour but through someone else's in
every locality even before the
revolution such cruel acts could be
numbered on one's fingers and the
revolution totally destroyed their basis
of activity subsequently after 1917 by a
transfer of meaning the name Kulak began
to be applied to all those who in any
way hired workers even if it was only
even if it was only when they were
temporarily short of working hands in
their own families but and that doesn't
stop there the inflation of this
scathingly term of this scathing term
cuckoo lock proceeded relentlessly
and by 1930 all strong peasants in
general who were being so-called all
peasants strong and management strong in
work or even strong merely in
convictions the term Kulik was used to
smash the strength of the peasantry and
I got I gotta go a little bit further
because helluva thing for the Workers
Party to do ain't crazy
yeah they went further though beyond
this in every village there were people
who in one way or another had personally
gotten in the way of the local activists
this was the perfect time to settle
accounts with them of jealousy envy and
insult these are the people you were
just talking about a new word was needed
for these new victims as a class and it
was borne by this time it had no social
or economic content whatsoever but it
had a marvelous sound pod kulaks Nick
and that meant a person aiding the
kulaks in other words I consider you an
accomplice of the enemy
yeah and that's all it took yeah well
one of the things I tried to outline in
my forward to the abridged version was I
was thinking about this idea of oddly
enough about intersectionality which is
a like social justice idea you know that
the social justice idea is that we're
best defined by our collective identity
and that the proper narrative in
relationship to our collective identity
is one of victim victimizer which is a
replay of the old Marxist doctrine of
burgeois Zi and proletariat it's just in
its new guise
I mean and that new guise developed at
least in part in response to the Gulag
Archipelago because the old proletariat
bourgeoisie distinction became morally
untenable so it just went underground
and underwent this transformation the
intersectional theorists point out that
your status as a victimizer or a victim
is actually the intersection of your
multiple identities and so and that's
actually the Achilles heel of the
collectivist notion and we can get into
why that is but there's a horror that
goes along with that that people that's
that's not obvious that I think
contributed to exactly why the Russian
Revolution went so horribly wrong and
that is that so imagine that I could
characterize you along five or six
different dimensions of group identity
it's pretty easy and while you're male
your male of a certain age your male of
a certain age and economic class you're
you have a certain sexual orientation
you have a certain ethnicity you have a
certain race that's six groups right
there and we could continue you know
your parents had a certain
socio-economic class and so did your
grandparents and and then your ethnic
group had a certain privilege or lack
thereof and you're attractive or you're
not attractive and you're intelligent or
you're not intelligent there's Templeman
temperamental variability like there's
all sorts of ways of characterizing you
according to your group okay now we
might say that if we were compassionate
people that we would take one of those
group identities or more and look at
where your dispossessed and victimized
okay and we're gonna find some dimension
along which you're less privileged than
some people like maybe you come from a
working-class background despite the
fact that you're like a straight male
and so you can be a victim on
dimension and so and that's kind of
that's at least in part an element of
intersectional theory right and that may
be your your your oppression is the
product of your multiple victim like
identities but that can easily be
reversed because it's absolutely the
case that I can take any person and I
can do add multi-dimensional analysis of
their group identities and I can find at
least one dimension along which they're
the perpetrator not the victim they're
the victimizer not the victim and as
soon as I can identify a dimension along
which they're a victimizer then that
justifies their persecution and so one
of the things that you saw happening in
the Russian Revolution and it's very
much akin to what you just described was
that the the the borders of who who was
validly accused of being a victimizer
essentially expanded to include everyone
and that's actually right in it's it's
in a perverse sense it's right because
if you position yourself properly in in
the historical flow then you should see
yourself as a perpetrator and a victim
equally well it's not the right way to
see yourself at all but if you're gonna
play that game you're gonna be on both
sides of it and then that issue is and
this is related to your idea about you
know in your platoon you've got one
person who's sadistic it's like okay
well let's even assume that at the
beginning of the Russian Revolution that
the vast majority of the people who were
motivated by communism were actually
compassionate with regards to the
dispossessed peasantry now I don't
believe that but weak we could say that
that was even a significant minority
well the question is did you just say on
it hmm what was your what was your a
hypothetical percentage well well let's
say well let's say it's 20% or let's
even say it's 50% of people who are
genuinely motivated by compassion for
the dispossessed but then there's
another minority maybe we could even say
it was only 10% to begin with who
weren't motivated by that at all they
were motivated by the jealousy and the
spite and the and and the resentment
that Solzhenitsyn describes and they
were the ones who were after those to be
persecuted
the thing is they got the upper-hand
really rapidly and it might be because
the carnivorous types the predatory
types are much more dangerous and
powerful than the compassionate types
like they'll take them out instantly
we're we're willing to step up and smash
someone yes most of the people that are
saying oh we just want to help
yes exactly well and there's someone I
actually cited a guy named I think his
name was Walter Lots us in the foreword
who who wrote wrote in a journal called
Red Terror that if you were
interrogating an enemy of the state you
didn't bother with niceties like their
individual guilt that was a burrs huazi
conceit and that's that's a really
important thing to keep in mind what you
wanted to do is to do a class-based
analysis and find out well are they a
member of let's say the Kulak or the
affiliates of the kulaks which is a
lovely way of expanding your list of
potential victims and then you you
execute accordingly and that would mean
well the person that you're
interrogating right or the class member
that you're interrogating and then their
children and perhaps also their
grandchildren and latsis himself was
eventually executed by the Stellan as
somebody wrote to me after i wrote the
foreword and told me that that was his
eventual fate and I thought well talk
about standing on a chair and putting
the noose around your own neck and
kicking it out from underneath you it's
like you know he basically he murdered
himself fundamentally and and you know
you could say in some sense that was the
story of the Soviet Union to it to a
tremendous degree yeah there's one part
going back to the ever-expanding people
that need to be destroyed there's a
point in in the book where he starts
he's saying hey look there's insects
Stalin's just described or maybe as
Lenin was describing these certain
people as insects you don't need to be
destroyed and then he just that that
just starts off with hey people that are
rabble rousers yeah they're insects and
and then it just expands and expands and
it's got priests and then it's got
engineers oh yeah and physicians and
physicians everyone in wreckers yeah
records that's that's the word that they
use there that he uses in the book for
first basically saboteurs yeah and that
expands beyond comprehension yeah
because at every single
problem that there is is the fault of
some person out there that sabotage yeah
and and they they do this show trial and
he talks about it in the book for I
think that I think the phrase that he
uses or that they use at the Russian
that the Soviets used was organizers of
the famine huh meaning like oh yeah
you're starving and these people over
here
they're the reason you're these new
people that organizes the famine they're
the Wreckers of production of food and
you bet you bet well it was either that
you know you imagined that you you you
adopt a worldview and that worldview
enables you to at least in principle
organize yourself with other people and
to provide you with a certain amount of
psychological stability and then things
go dreadfully wrong and then you have a
choice which is to reevaluate your
worldview which is of course what
Solzhenitsyn does in the Gulag
Archipelago in a very deep ways
reorganize his entire worldview or you
can look for reasons why you're right
and and these things are happening and
Solzhenitsyn talks a lot in the Gulag
Archipelago about see he had a moral
conundrum when he was in prison and he
started his moral awakening let's say
and he was trying to figure out how to
treat other people who were imprisoned
he had a real moral conundrum when a
committed communist was dragged into the
gulag system which happened all the time
he said those people were in
particularly dire straits because not
only had they been subject to the entire
tyrannical weight of the deceitful state
but it was at the hands of their own
comrades and friends and then the the
the committed communists would enter the
gulag and they would still be in they're
morally superior phase right that that
their incarceration was a mistake and
that things would be set right and that
there was nothing wrong with the system
and they would attempt to justify it and
Solzhenitsyn was not never sure how to
react to these people ethically because
on the one hand well they were you know
devastated because now they were
political prisoners and maybe they got a
20 year sentence and they were in
terrible you know stripped of their
family and just ruined but on the other
hand they were still avid supporters of
the very fist that had crushed them and
so his eventual conclusion
that until they broke and repented they
they weren't to be allied with they were
still essentially on the side of the
while of the perpetrator and it seems to
me that that that's right that's that's
unrepentant sin let's say and it isn't
until you what would you say until you
take responsibility for your own
complicit 'no sin your in your unfair
interrogation that you get to join the
ranks of of valuable and suffering
humanity again and so yeah it's that the
the extension of the persecution is
really something that's horrifying
to see how who constituted the
victimizer
the ranks of who constituted victimizer
just grew and grew and grew one of the
most shocking groups of people that
ended up in the gulags were the damn
soviet soldiers then it just got back oh
yeah that's the only thing you can't
make up you can't make that up fucking
social mission who who was like in close
combat with the enemy and he wrote a
letter to one of his buddies and said
yeah this is doesn't seem like to be a
great decision by stalin yeah and next
thing you know he's he's in yeah in
prison yeah well the stellen stellen
decided that yeah this is something that
you you you can't you can't release this
well it is there is this like it's like
you know if there's something satanic at
the bottom of this you know
mythologically speaking there's also
something that's like a cosmic it's like
cosmic black humor it's like the the
sign on auswitch that said work will set
you free
you know if that's a joke right it's a
it's a terrible terrible dark joke and
so much of this has the element of of
exactly that kind of surreal I hate to
say humor but it's it's right
I mean Stalin decided that the okay so
the Soviet prisoners of war were not
covered by the Geneva Convention for the
treatment of prisoners of war because
Stalin refused to sign that agreement so
like if you were an Allied prisoner of
the Germans it wasn't like you were
having a great time
of it like food was in short supply and
you were treated pretty brutally but the
Soviets were kept separately and they
were doing so badly that the Allies used
to throw food packets over the fence
when that was an option so the Soviet
prisoners of war were treated absolutely
dreadfully and and now and Stellan
didn't care about that
and then when they were released and
went back to the Soviet Union
his dictum was that because they had
been exposed to the capitalist West or
even the Nazi West for that matter that
they had now been intolerably corrupted
on ideological grounds and had to be put
in the prison camps so that was the that
was your destiny as you know I mean
first of all you were a frontline
Russian soldier which was just brutal
beyond belief their army was completely
unprepared for Hitler's invasion because
Stalin trusted Hitler in in his strange
way and so they were completely
unprepared and of course then fighting
in the Soviet Union with its winters I
mean you just you just can't imagine
what that must have been like and then
to be thrown in a prisoner of war camp
at the bottom of the rung and then to be
brought back to your country and then to
be imprisoned as a traitor because as a
class you'd been exposed to the wrong
ideology it's like you just it's it's
it's unimaginably vile and surreal at
the same time and it is shake your hand
for me well it's such a shock to read
the Gulag Archipelago you just can't
it's it's like it is it's like Dante's
Inferno it's like a trip into hell
and yeah I guess you're that's what I
was trying to say when we started this
conversation I was trying to say that
it's like you're watching this like like
you said it's like a bad comedy movie
and you'd think well that's that'd be
really that way you'd think you know
when you take a comedy well one of the
things one of the ways you can make
people laugh is to take something
ordinary and maybe make it much more
extreme in the more extreme you make it
the more funny it becomes that's what
like happened here you're looking at
this thing going hey oh yeah that they
seem to be trying to make this funny
because who in could ever conceive that
you could take your frontline soldiers
who
were captured and in misery and when
they return home instead of treating
them like heroes instead you put them
back into a prison the worse one even
you can't even you can't even that's
just that's no no you can't make this
stuff up can't make it up no did you see
I believe that movie was the death of
Stalin did you I did not oh yeah but
that's worth seeing because it's it's
very interesting because one of the
things about that movie is that it
captures that surreal element because
it's a black comedy you know and and
there are comical things happening in
the movie in that terrible dark way
constantly at the same time that in the
background genuinely terrible things are
happening so it's that horrible it's
that it's it's got that horrible
satirical flavor that runs through books
like The Gulag Archipelago where you
think well this just no this is so
absurd that there's no possible way it
could have occurred and yet that's not
only did it happen there was like a
contest to top the absurdity you know to
to consider the engineers for example
wreckers as well these people were
building the Soviet system to the degree
that it was built and then to turn
around and accuse exactly those people
of being the ones who destroy and
undermine it it's it's part of I really
think that what's what underlies this
whatever this is and I think this is
what manifests itself in the worst of
the leftist collectivism is a real
hatred for anything that smacks of
competence at all like I I tried to
imagine those Russian villages because I
come from a small town a small northern
town too so I kind of I tried to imagine
so imagine that you're in an isolated
village and it's a peasant village and
the peasants weren't freed that long ago
right they were basically serfs until
until about the the middle of the second
half of the nineteenth century and so
they had been emancipated and then some
of those people who were emancipated got
a little bit of land and started to have
a life you know started to be successful
peasants and they were also the people
that grew the bulk of the crops because
what you see happening in any productive
domain is that a small percentage of
people do almost all the productive work
so there's a small percentage of
productive farmers who grew all the
crops right and then there's all sorts
of farmers who were only farmers by name
and they weren't successful at all so
you have and then there was a certain
relationship between being productive as
a farmer and developing some wealth
maybe you had a house and maybe you
could hire a person or two you know and
which you think would be actually be a
good thing especially if you were also
growing food okay so you imagine you you
get a village and now there's a bit of a
socio-economic pyramid and there's some
people that are doing well and they're
really and they're and it isn't the
crooked people that are really annoying
though people who like the genuine cool
acts let's say that that small
percentage of psychopathic types who are
basically
profiting criminally off the efforts of
others those aren't so annoying those
people because they're rich but they
don't deserve it and so they don't stand
towards you as a moral ideal that shames
you but the really annoying people are
the ones who are doing well and deserve
it especially if you're someone who's
doing nothing and is bitter okay so now
so there's the village and you've got
your people who are doing alright and
then you've got a huge strata of people
who aren't upset about the people who
are doing well they might even admire
them and be happy that they're around
because they're making the community
thrive and growing some food then you
have this little this little strata at
the bottom of people who are near do
wells and on the more psychopathic end
of things and they are bitter and
resentful and and waiting for their
bloody opportunity and then the
communist intellectuals come into town
and say you know those people that are
doing well they actually everything
they've got is ill-gotten and they they
stole it and they stole it from you from
you like and look at how badly you're
doing and the reason you're doing badly
is because these these people who are
lording it over you and who have all
this creature comfort they they took
that from you it's yours by right and so
then all that resentment and jealousy
and hatred and rage alcohol-fueled as
you might well imagine has this moral
reason to go with pitchforks and and in
a mob and surround those houses and to
strip them of everything they have and
to rape the women and to kill the
occupants or to ship them off to the
middle of Siberia when they're where
they froze to death because there were
no
or died of dysentery or or whatever
other plague managed to you know weave
its way through these camps and so you
have the you have the intellectuals
providing the moral rationale for the
worst ethical actors in these small
villages doing the worst possible things
under the guise of compassion right and
that's part of that victim victimizer
narrative it's just an engineering like
you could imagine that you can imagine a
dark night you can imagine the winter
you can imagine the alcohol you can
imagine the rage that fuels these people
who are drinking too much in the pubs
that have been sitting there for the
last twenty years like what would you
say eating up their own Souls with
resentment and bitterness and then
someone comes in and says you're the
true victim here and here's the people
that you can go after and then like if
you play that on your imagination you
get some real sense of exactly what sort
of horror that would produce you know
well you think about the rape for
example or or just the theft or but but
it's the rape that you can really think
about us as absolute revenge for all
that bitter resentment all fueled by the
fact that you know you'd sat there for
the last twenty years being completely
goddamn useless and bitter and and and
and angry and and and and fantasizing
about the day that would come where
you'd have your opportunity God and then
the whole country and that was the whole
country oh it was just unbelievable yeah
and I think of he spells that out very
clearly and he says it's you know what
he's saying you know I'm saying that
you've got a psychopath in your platoon
he's saying that psychopath all that
psychopath needs to flip is is the is
someone to tell them that that's the
right thing to do and that's exactly
what happened what you said that's it
yes guys that were slightly psychopathic
yeah and then it becomes okay I'm the on
the head psychopath and you're in my
village and you're let's say you're one
of those people that are in the middle
well whose side you're gonna be on I'm a
psychopath if you if you're not on my
side I'm gonna kill you next
yeah so you go oh no I'm on your side -
yeah and that's it doesn't tailor kits
not like it takes much pressure on
people to have them for
I mean one of the things you see you see
happening right now in our cultures
that's happening to people all the time
with these twitter wars you know someone
will say something they'll express an
opinion and then they'll get mobbed by
and but only abstractly right it's not
like there's pitchfork wielding mobs at
their house and I'm not making light of
it it's no it's no pleasant thing to be
mobbed on Twitter but that's that's an
abstraction compared to these people
showing up at your house you know and
yeah and what will happen is that people
will go through an abject apology you
know and they'll say well I really
didn't mean it and now I understand what
my privilege is and I see how what I
said could have been very hurtful to
people and you know they they wander
through that entire apology and fold
almost instantly and and that's under
almost almost no pressure compared to
what real pressure is and real pressure
is when the wolves are actually at your
door rather than just barking off in the
distance but people will fold just when
they're barking in the distance so
there's one lawyer that he talks about
in here is the same thing as the destroy
the new scribe I forget the guys name
but this guy was like the premier
prosecuting lawyer for the Soviet
government and he just rips people apart
over and over again and as you read
about what happens to him sure enough
he's one of the guys that that ended up
on the on the defensive and yeah being
executed yeah like yeah I see style they
built they built a place of butchery and
then threw themselves into it you know
that's a no and you see social nets and
documents this very carefully I mean
Stalin killed all the people who who
were foremost actors in the Russian
Revolution right so I mean everyone was
fed into the great grinding machine so
and and Stalin himself I mean it looked
to me like see he got himself into
something approximating a positive
feedback loop which is a very dangerous
thing to have happen and I think
Solzhenitsyn does a lovely job of
detailing this as well so it's like
imagine that I have a fair amount of
contempt for people to begin with and
then I find that people are I'm not a
trusting person
I find that I'm very paranoid about the
fact that people are lying to me and
then I develop a certain amount of power
and a reputation well then people really
do start lying to me all the time in
every gesture you know because every
time they come near me they're
absolutely terrified and they're gonna
tell me anything that I want to hear and
of course then all that does is validate
my view of how pathetic and contemptible
everyone is and so and the more that
view gets validated the more I think
that it's okay to destroy people because
look at how pathetic and contemptible
they are how they always lie and all
that means is that they lie even more
and so this whole thing just spirals out
of control and you know Stalin basically
started out as a as the brutal
enforcement henchman for henchman for
Lenin
right the killer for hire and not like
Lenin was above that sort of thing
himself but but he trained Stalin and
and then Stalin's proclivity to be
murderous just kept expanding without
limit right first of all it was
individuals and then it was groups and
then it was nations and then well by the
end of his life well what was it
the plot to destroy the entire world to
to to to to to initiate the third world
war to wipe out Europe to maybe destroy
everything and and like there's no limit
there was no limit to that you know and
there's some evidence that that's
perhaps why he was killed
you know because Stalin himself even
went too far for the horrible for the
horrible
what semi the corrupted compadres that
he had he'd arranged around himself he
went too far even for them and thank God
for that you know but yeah it's it's
it's absolutely I mean the thing that
that the Gulag Archipelago Gulag
Archipelago did for me and this was also
in keeping as a consequence also of
reading young at the same time but but
it was certainly the GU like in in large
part that did it I would say that in
some sense it scared me straight I
thought oh I see the the consequences of
unethical behavior deceit the
willingness to to turn a blind eye
so even sins of omission rather than
sins of commission just to turn a blind
eye the consequences of that are so
absolutely dreadful that it's not
acceptable and I think that's the right
lesson from the 20th century it's that
you you you you you have a much more
important moral role to play in keeping
things straight then you want to believe
you know people think well my life is
basically meaningless it's like well
that's quite terrifying it's like yeah
it's kind of terrifying but you know it
means you don't have any responsibility
so there's a big advantage to thinking
that you know now if nothing you do
matters then nothing you do matters and
so you can do whatever you want and and
that's horrifying Anna nihilistic sort
of way but there's another kind of
horror that's more associated I think
with the horror of hellfire that was
characteristic of the medieval christian
view is which is something like and if
you strip it of its metaphysics it's
something like no you don't get it the
things you do actually do the things you
do or don't do they actually do matter
and they tilt the world towards you know
something approximating good let's say
or towards something that very closely
approximates hell and that's actually on
you it's literally your fault it's
literally your responsibility it's like
man that's a terrifying night that's a
terrifying idea but I can't see how you
can read this literature without coming
to that conclusion like it wasn't one
that I wanted to leap to you know it's
like as it sits it's sort of the
ultimate in horrifying conclusions that
that everybody who participated in this
system was at fault for all of it in
Owen Dostoyevsky made the same sorts of
claims in in in the last part of the
19th century I mean he was a very weird
mystical sort of person you know and he
he made claims or some of his characters
did but on his behalf that you know not
only are you responsible for everything
you do but in some sense you're
responsible for everything that everyone
else does too and you think well
obviously there's a way in which that
isn't true
you know it's delusional in some sense
but there's another way in which it
actually is true you know and so well I
I wrote a book called extreme ownership
and it's it's very interesting
so all this is as a whole
thought here so you know when I read the
book about face which is not about
leadership it's not a leadership book
it's a book about a guy that was in the
leadership position but he doesn't say
here's how you lead here's what you do
here it's a book about his experience
and what I took away from it especially
because I was in leadership positions in
in the military in combat situations
that I started seeing all these
leadership things that he did and
there's all this crossover because for
instance and so for me the crossover was
well I started learning about tactics
when I was a young kid because I was in
the military and the SEAL Teams and you
had to learn about how to fire and
maneuver like that's what you do and
then so you start learning about
leadership and then I started training a
lot of jujitsu and so those things kind
of all fit together and it's very
strange how those things started to
weave together in my head that oh if on
the battlefield if you want to attack
the enemy you don't do it head-on
you you flank them you distract them and
then you flank them you come in from the
other side in jujitsu if you want to
submit your opponent you you don't just
grab their arm no you start to choke
them and while they're defending the
choke then you get their arm and as a
leader if you want somebody to do
something you just don't bark that order
at them you flank them and you let them
understand why it's happening and and
you know when I started this podcast
that I do I I started off by saying in
the beginning I'd say that's a podcast
about leadership viewed through the lens
of war and atrocity and the more I did
it it didn't take me very long when I
was saying waltz it's actually a podcast
about human nature really as what it's
actually about because the better you
understand human beings the better
you'll be able to do as a leader because
you'll understand what's happening with
those dynamics which I guess is now
leading me into some sort of psychology
you're just kind of where you ended up
with live of you read this book and you
said you were studying political science
when you read this book and then you
said oh you looked at the psychology of
it and an example that you just brought
up and this is just what you learn when
you read and when you understand history
and when you understand the way people
think stalin's surrounded himself with
people that would say yes to him
and anybody that didn't say yes to him
he killed them and I'll say this again
I'll talk to military she also killed
you if you said yes yeah
the I'll talk to military for sure but
also any business leader we talk to
business leaders all the time and you
don't want people you don't want your
subordinates or your superiors when you
tell them what to do to just nod their
head and say yes you don't want that now
the the the immediate fought especially
for a military guy they think they're
nothing would make my job easier
then if I bark an order at you Jordan
you work from you're a private and nama
captain and I bark an order you know you
just shut up and go do it that seems
like the best thing in the world it's
absolutely not true
because there's things that you know on
the front lines that I don't know and if
I really want to be a good leader I want
you to push back on me and say hey boss
we don't want to do that here's what's
going on let me tell you the situation
and instead of man you want to be able
to do that you want to be able to teach
your subordinates to do that without
being insubordinate right because then
it's not a power play it's that your
your interests are aligned our interests
are aligned and I actually when I talk
to the subordinates cuz I talked to
subordinates - yeah and I say listen
would you say something to your boss you
don't say why the hell are we doing that
because you actually have to be very
tacky yes yes exactly
hey hey pay boss um I want to make sure
I'm executing this exactly how you want
it can you explain to me why we're doing
this so I can really really make it
happen out there in the field you know
and that's a key thing so so these ideas
of you know psychology I guess now is I
hate to use that word but because I was
just calling a human nature but these
ideas they all kind of come together and
so now you're talking about ownership
right extreme ownership and this idea
that hey I'm responsible for everything
and and so here's what I getting from a
leader hmm they'll say well whether it's
a business leader or it's it's very easy
to use a military leader so I'll get a
platoon commander my machine gunner shot
in the wrong direction how can that be
my fault
mm-hmm because my machine gunner shot in
the wrong correct I'm not I'm not
holding his weight and I'm not feeling
his trigger man how can that possibly be
my fault that's not my fault
wrong who's in charge of that machine
gun who's in charge of making sure he
what is fields of fire who's in charge
of making sure he understands when and
where he's allowed to shoot you are
you're the boss
this is absolutely your fault had it
another interesting example of the
weather the weather's bad we couldn't
execute our mission that's why we failed
because we couldn't launch our
helicopter yeah it's not my fault yeah
that's a hard one to argue against yeah
except for the fact that if you're a
good leader you'll say hey here's our
plan we're gonna use these helicopters
and here's our contingency now right if
there's bad weather yeah if you don't
take that ownership of what's going on
if you don't take responsibility for it
you're not gonna change it you're not
gonna fix it and that means you're never
getting any better you're not gonna win
right
but the minute us end this and obviously
this applies to you know people to
purple in and you know you tell people
to take responsibility I've you know
tell them take ownership but what's
going on in your world it's this it's
the same thing but at the end well it's
also it also seems to me to be the case
and I think that this is part of the
ethic that's embedded in in it's deeply
embedded in Christianity with the idea
that the idea that the ultimate
sacrifice that you can offer to the
world is the sacrifice of yourself it's
like well imagine that you have to
sacrifice something to set the world
right while you do obviously because you
have to give up things now in order to
make things better in the future so the
sacrificial idea is a very deep one then
the question might be well well if
you're gonna sacrifice something is it
going to be someone else or is it going
to be you and I really think that's the
fundamental question and the right
answer to that is that it's gonna be you
it's your fault right you take that on
or at least you take on that
responsibility and it is it's a weird
thing
weirdly difficult to distinguish fault
and responsibility I think
responsibility is the better way of
thinking about it but it's tied in with
the idea of fault if it doesn't go right
if it isn't going right it's because
you're not good enough now that can be
crushing there is a problem with that
like and you see sometimes people who
develop like psychotic depression and
they they they suffer from a delusional
condition in some sense that the entire
moral catastrophe of the world is
literally their fault and that's not
there's an element of that that's that's
not productive
although there's a truth in it as well
no and and it's hard to it's hard to
find the balance so that you can take on
that responsibility without it
simultaneously being a crushing weight
because there's a lot of things in the
world that are really not good and if
they're your fault well that's rather
hard on you I mean one of the things
that the Catholic Church does to help
people with that is that it gives them
the opportunity to sort of wash their
sins off themselves right you can go to
church and you can say well look here's
a bunch of ways that I've been being not
who I could be and the church
authorities say well you know that's not
good and you should straighten up and
all of that and fly right but human
beings are fallible and you're fallible
and and and we can't just crush you
because of your insufficiency so we'll
wash the slate clean and you can go out
there and try again and and it's very
hard to get the balance between those
things right so that you can take the
responsibility on without being crushed
by it but but it's still the case that
it seems to me that it's either your
fault or it's someone else's and as soon
as it's someone else's then you better
be careful because that idea that it's
someone else's is definitely gonna
appeal to the worst in you that's
definitely going to happen and if you
don't see that then you're naive or
willfully blind and and all that is
gonna do all that's all that that is
going to do is make the situation worse
yeah especially because if it's not my
fault and it's your fault and I can't
control you what do I do about it
I sit there and it just suffer the
consequences of the situation as opposed
to okay here's what's going on I'm gonna
take responsibility and ownership for
what I'm gonna change it you make it
happen
you talked about turning a blind eye and
earlier you talked about turning a blind
eye to the truth to a situation and I
know there's a point in this book where
he talks about he's got a buddy that
says amnesty is coming right amnesty is
coming let's just keep our mouth shut
let's do what we're told to do and we'll
get you know we'll get out yeah I'm
coming and you know social medicine says
he's saying okay yeah
then he says to himself wait a minute if
I'm not if I'm not living in order to
live then is it worth it mm-hmm
and this is a question that I get asked
a lot because people get themselves into
situations where they've lost some kind
of control whether it's they're in a
crappy job or they've got a bad boss
yeah or whatever maybe they're in a bad
relationship
maybe their families met but they're
they're in a situation and they and they
don't know what to do and part of them
I think anticipates the answer from me
to be listen hey listen if you're not if
you're not living in order to live then
you that's wrong but what I actually
tell them universally almost and there's
a couple situations where it goes
outside this but you it's like what I
tell them is what you need to do right
now is you need to play the game you
need to play the game to get the
situation to a point where you can act
right so if you're you got a bad boss
right yeah oh you okay you got a bye
boss I want to tell this guy to go screw
himself yeah yeah hey guess what I'm
gonna do when my boss tells me something
to do that it doesn't make much sense
you know what I'm gonna do I'm gonna do
it and I'm gonna do it well and what am
i doing I'm building that relationship
with him he's starting to trust me and
he's gonna tell me up to do something
else now these things are massive Kitaj
de catastrophes it's like he's telling
me to do something maybe there's a
better way to do it
you don't know how to do it that way
mm-hmm and I'm gonna play that game and
I'm gonna build up that relationship now
when eventually he tells me to do
something that is totally stupid or it's
gonna cost you no lives or money then
when I say hey boss that's not a great
way to do it I think I know a better way
couldn't we try something else he
actually will listen to me so I'm gonna
play the game a little bit and I'll tell
you my gut instinct if now I guess it's
it's easy to look from the outside and
say hey if I was in this prison camp my
gut instinct is like okay jock would you
know you've been through these kind of
things before play the game you're gonna
play the game
which is horrifying hmm because part of
playing that game to the fullest extent
here or in a Nazi prison camp would
becoming a capo yeah oh you're playing
the game yet yeah you're playing the
game yeah so and that's really the
outlying that the things that I said
that are outlying I always make the
caveat that if you're getting asked to
do something that's immoral illegal or
unethical then you actually have a duty
to say no I'm not gonna do that no
that's the that's the line which you
know which you reach that line in the
sand with Bill c16 what which is hey I'm
not going to do this but the idea that
sometimes you got to play the game and
yeah well that's even from you when you
just said to me you said well you know
sometimes you it's not right to turn a
blind eye on things and it's like
sometimes you have to if you want to get
yourself to a position like my well it
seems to me that you're making a
distinction between discipline and
strategy like and and and and like
impulsive moral responding you know like
let's say that you are in a situation
where you have a boss who's intolerable
and maybe what you'd like to do you know
the resentment has built up over five
years and you'd like to go in there and
and yell at them and tell them
everything you think and you think well
that's the truth it's like well it's
actually it's not a very sophisticated
truth because you're doing as shallow
and impulsive analysis of this situation
like it would have been the case that
you've already compromised yourself in
500 ways and I'll get back to the
playing the game issue because you do
have to discipline yourself to and and
you have to discipline yourself to some
degree by allowing yourself to do
arbitrary things that are part of the
system right that's necessary part of
discipline and discriminating that from
compliance with unethical activity is
very difficult so that's a hard
situation but let's say you're you're
you're going to counsel someone who has
an intolerable boss and they come in and
they're right at the end of their tether
because maybe that's why they come for
counseling they say I really want to
tell that son of a bitch what I think of
him and you think well wait a second
here okay first of all you've already
eradicated
from the list of reasonable
possibilities that decision by failing
to say small things that you could have
said all the way along and it's not like
you can just all of a sudden blurt all
of that out now and that wipes the slate
clean in that constitutes truth it's too
unsophisticated so let's think okay so
what is it that you want well I don't
want this job anymore it's like okay now
let's actually have a strategy about
this then you don't want this job
anymore can you get another job
well I don't think so well so you can't
just quit well no I can't because then I
don't have any money and my family
depends on the job it's like okay so you
can't just stop this that's not a viable
solution you go out of the frying pan
into the fire or you know you suck you
you substitute one set of unethical
actions for another set of unethical
actions that are even worse that's not
helpful
all right so let's start thinking about
what exactly it is that you want it's
like well maybe I want a better job I
want to work for someone who's more
reasonable
okay so what's stopping you well I don't
have my CV in order my resume isn't up
to date well why is that well I haven't
done it for five years and I don't like
doing it well why is that well because
I'm kind of embarrassed about it because
it has holes in it then it shows where
I'm lackadaisical and where I'm not
prepared it's like okay how many things
are there like that well there's a bunch
of things and they're all associated
with how I procrastinated in the past
it's like okay what are we going to do
to rectify that so I'll say to people
why don't you update your CV that's what
we'll do first because if you're going
to look for a different job I'm not
saying you're gonna look for a different
job but if you're going to look for a
different job you're not going to unless
you're CVS updated this one is not going
to unless you can get a good
recommendation from this boss that's a
Terran and so that's right there's new
god there's Tanis strategic actions that
you're gonna have to take in order to
make yourself able to move laterally or
up and the truth is isn't going in and
yelling at your boss and telling them
everything you think about them the
truth is trying to figure out the very
very difficult process of how you put
yourself in a better position and now
that like one of the things that's quite
fun about this
lecture tour is the letters that I
receive or the stories that people tell
me about switching jobs because they do
realize that there and I often talk to
people about consulting their resentment
resentments are really useful emotion
like it's really dangerous it's one of
the most dangerous psychological states
I believe but it's unbelievably useful
because resentment usually only means
one of two things it either means quit
whining and and take it on because
you're immature or it means you're
allowing yourself to be taken advantage
of and you have something to say or do
and so you want to sort out the first
part and find out if you're just being
immature and you can think that through
and you can talk to people and but in
that but if it's the second it's like no
you've compromised yourself in a variety
of ways and you have to figure out how
to get out of that and if you're
resentful that's evidence that you have
in fact done that okay so now that issue
would be well how can you set your life
up so that you can be without that
resentment and so that's when you start
to develop a strategy for you know and
and Menen venture in this too I mean
I've had a number of clients who have
been in jobs that they didn't like at
all and you know they were terrorized by
someone for example and they were also
working below their hypothetical level
and we'd put together a plan it's like
okay you're gonna make three times as
much money in in five years that's the
plan
but like that's not gonna be simple so
you there's education you got to educate
yourself maybe formally cuz you've got
holes you got to fix up your resume
you've got to you've got to overcome
your fear of being interviewed you have
to start sending out like 50 resumes a
week on a regular basis and be prepared
for a 99% rejection rate you you're
going to look for a different job it's
probably going to take six months to a
year and almost all of that is going to
be rejection you got to steal yourself
from for that and prepare and maybe this
is going to be a three year process it's
no trivial thing but you know it's
almost inevitably I can't remember a
single example where the consequence of
that very careful detailed strategic
thinking wasn't massively substantive in
in socio-economic positioning and a
great movement towards a improving
trajectory and and and there's
advantages even along the way because
even before that happens the fact that
you're taking genuine steps to put
yourself in a better situation
immediately starts to reduce your
resentment even if it isn't having
positive consequences to begin with but
you have to be realistic about it's like
look it's gonna be hard to update your
CV because you're embarrassed about it
and you should be alright it's no wonder
you're embarrassed about it and then
well of course you don't want to go be
interviewed because you're not very good
at it and and there's holes in your
story and and your and you can be made
nervous easily and you're not a very
good advocate for yourself so there's a
lot of improvement that needs to be done
there and and then you have to withstand
the the the punishment of being
constantly rejected when you apply for
jobs because the baseline rejection rate
you know for the for the typical job
applicant is like 99 percent it's like
the rejection rate for everything is
this gonna work no but if you do it a
hundred times
it might work once that's and that's all
you need that's exactly you you you only
need that once and so the truth there
isn't to yell at your boss the truth
there is to get your life together yeah
play the game you gotta play the game
sometimes to to get a strategic win to
me and that's and another interesting
thing here is as I say you don't want to
surround yourself with yes-men when
you're a leadership position you also
don't want to be your own personal
yes-man that just thinks you're great
and agrees with everything that you're
doing and and won't tell yourself the
hard truth you know you can't lie to
yourself everything every little one of
those things that you just listed off
are the kind of things that people just
lie to themselves and say yeah you know
what well you don't really need that
that person didn't learn anything and
that in that course why should I go to
it that you know it's like if you don't
tell yourself the truth about your what
your situation is it's gonna be
problematic just like if you don't have
people on your team above you or below
you in the chain of command that tell
you the truth that's gonna be
problematic as well which is something
here which is something that's easier
so they're playing the game thing so are
you thinking about that as a consequence
of necessary discipline you know like
because they're weak because it seems to
be you're making two cases at the same
time right one is that you should
obviously not undertake unethical
actions but then by the same token and
and you have to subordinate yourself to
the realities of the situation and and I
think that that's psychologically true
because you're always in a situation
where if you're in an organization
there's kind of an arbitrary and
tyrannical aspect to it because it's
never working perfectly and then and
then there's the the positive aspect to
it too and so whenever you're doing a
job it could be that you're you're
called upon to do things that what would
you say that are a necessary part of the
operation of the machinery I guess that
would be particularly true in military
situation yes and let me give you these
well just a broad example right you know
my personality and my reputation is that
you know when I was in the military it's
like oh it's Jocko
he's not gonna you know he's if someone
tells him to do something doesn't want
to do he's just gonna you know say screw
you yeah we're not doing we're doing it
my way
you know um I got the nut butt and that
was kind of the impression people would
get from me if they didn't know me from
the outside they think oh this guy's a
knuckle-dragger he's just gonna go
forward he's gonna make things happen
and he's not gonna listen anyone else
that was the impression from the outside
the reality is a you you can't do that
and and be the reality is what my
actions right I'd have you know a young
lieutenant would come to me and say hey
you know my bosses do tell me to do this
this and this and what they think I was
gonna say is like bro you don't do that
right and up you don't screw you that
doesn't make any sense and maybe they
get this look in their eyes of surprise
yeah when I say oh your boss want you to
do that do it do it well play the game
that's what I'm tell him to do is play
the game because these things are
meaningless it's um you know if
something is pathetic was like no you
got to fill out a form a certain way
it's like hey shut up and play the game
you look even Maya so is that a Madol
matter of picking your battles it
certainly is a matter of picking your
battles and
as that's part of strategy right like
everything can't be the war exactly and
it's exactly what it is but you know a
good example and we wrote about it in in
dichotomy of leadership which is you
know my friend my guy that worked for me
Lafe babban we were getting told to do
all this paperwork you gotta you gotta
fill out these forms you've gotta you
got to have a serialized inventory of
everything it's gotta be signed off this
many days we need to know the the
qualifications of each and every person
and when their qualifications come up
due and all these just ridiculous
paperwork and Lafe came to me and with
with the other platoon commander guy
named SEF that came to me and said oh
man this is bullshit why do we got to do
all this paperwork we're we're here
training for war we're getting ready for
war why we got to do this and you know
life will tell you his and expectation
was that I was gonna be like you're
right I'm gonna go to the commanding
officer and tell him screw this we're
not doing this stuff this is crap we're
trying to prepare because we were in
training getting ready to deploy to Iraq
this is crap we're not doing this and I
looked at him and said oh we're doing
all of this paperwork and not only are
we gonna do this paperwork we're gonna
do it better than anyone else and we're
gonna turn it in before it's even due
and you know both him and Seth were kind
of taken aback then the fact that I
wasn't standing up and saying we're not
doing this crap and then I explained him
here's what we're doing we're building a
relationship with my commanding officer
with our commanding officer we're gonna
do these little things for him we're
gonna play the game because at some
point two things are gonna happen number
one we want to build trust with my boss
I want my boss to look at me and when he
tells me to do to fill out paperwork he
knows is gonna be filled out if he wants
me to take down a building he knows it's
gonna get taken out if he wants me to
execute a a larger mission I'll go and
get it done we're built if I can't fill
out paperwork correctly
how can he trust me to go on and on a
real operation to have guys lives at
risk
so the idea is like hey we're gonna play
the game and I think sometimes people
start to hear me they start to listen to
me and their first instinct is Jaco
wouldn't put up with them shit yeah and
that's why these you know they'll hit me
up the same thing they'll write me an
email they'll write me a letter and say
here's the situation I'm in I'm whether
it's a boss whether it's a military it's
any of them
it's their wife like like my wife
expects me not to train jiu-jitsu it's
something as stupid is that like my wife
won't let me train it's driving me crazy
it's really starting to bother me
but why won't she well what's the
problem hey have you taken her out for
dinner
you mean like play the damn game a
little bit so that you can win
strategically and if the same thing I
think with your with the 12 rules we're
like hey
tell the truth or at least don't lie
it's like I get it but there's a
dichotomy in that statement and that is
if you run around telling the absolute
truth everyone it's gonna be like that
Jim Carrey movie where he can't say
anything that's not 100% true and he you
know Gert woman says good morning and he
says you look fat you know it's like one
of those like that very not good and so
you gotta learn to play the game and and
I guess again going back to this book
it's like that's a tough call to make in
these situations
how much do you play the game and
there's a an ethical line that you could
cross at some point if I become a cop oh
hey mm-hmm you just you played the game
and you went too far with it and just
like in a leadership situation if Ike if
you're my boss and I'm just kissing your
ass and do whatever you say
my guys lose respect for me yeah my team
will lose respect for me if you tell me
to do something completely stupid and I
say hey guys that's what the boss says
we're doing it my guys will lose respect
for me and I won't be I won't be able to
execute missions the way I should if
when the pushback is proper I say hey
hey boss yeah that doesn't make any
sense we shouldn't do that and I go to
the guys and say listen I told I talked
to him we're gonna see what he says but
trust me if we have to do this we'll
we'll figure out a way to make it work
because if you're just the guy that's
totally on board if you're a brown-noser
right you're Pete your guys will lose
respect for you 100% they will they'll
lose respect for you if you don't play
the game at all and you push back on
everything that your boss says you're
gonna you're not gonna get fired yeah
that's another ethical situation like if
my mom if you're my boss and you tell me
to do something that's I don't believe
in or it's like a bad plan and I may I
draw the line in the sand and say screw
you Jordan we're not doing it you can
fire me you're like okay fine you fire
me you get some yes-man to come in he
takes my guys out on the mission and get
some all killed he didn't mitigate the
risk proper
it's better for me ethically to say hey
look Jordan I don't agree with this plan
I really wish we could do it another way
is there any way I could flex on it you
say nope you're doing it this way it is
better for me in many situations to say
okay oh I got it indication of the
complexity of the truth I mean one of
the rules of thumb that I think is worth
abiding by and I guess this is something
that makes me somewhat conservative in
some ways is that you should do what
everyone else does unless there's a very
good reason not to and and I think
that's I think that's the same idea that
you're putting forward which is that if
you if you do fight back against
everything then you're just rebel
without a cause right in you and you
discredit yourself entirely and if you
accept everything well then you're not
even there and so there's some judicious
analysis of the situation that helps you
understand when the time for action is
right and most of the time what you're
doing in life is you're doing what other
people do and that's going along with
the game that's part of being socialized
but there's going to be times when the
right thing to do is to break a rule and
to do it very carefully and so and
there's a there's a there's a there's a
scene I think this is a New Testament
scene but it might be in some of the
apocryphal right apocryphal writings I
don't remember so Christ is walking down
the road on the Sabbath and there's
there's a ditch by the road and it's
very hot and in the ditch there's a hole
and in the hole there's a sheep and so
the sheep is stuck in the hole and this
guy Shepherd is trying to get the Sheep
out of the hole and Christ walks by and
he says if you don't understand what
you're doing you're a transgressor of
the law and you're cursed but if you do
understand what you're doing then you're
blessed so it's it's it's a perfect
example of that a because it's it's like
if you're okay now
here's your situation you're a shepherd
and you're supposed to be taking care of
that sheep right but it's the Sabbath
day so you're not supposed to be working
now if you have decided you've thought
this through you think it's the Sabbath
day this is something that everybody
needs because everybody needs to take a
rest and this is a rule I shouldn't
break because everybody needs to take a
rest or things degenerate
and I understand that and I have a lot
of respect for it but I think that in
this situation it's still morally
appropriate for me to break that rule in
this slight way and get this poor sheep
out of this hole
then while Christ's judgment was well
then you're exactly on the right track
but if you're doing it carelessly and
stupidly you're breaking that rule then
you're a transgressor of the law and
you're cursed and I think that's exactly
at the essence of what you're describing
it's like you play by the rules but then
there's a meta rule which is now and
then you break the rules and you do that
very very carefully because when you
break the rules you're breaking the
rules and the rules are what keep peace
they're what keep peace and order and so
you break them only in the service of a
higher peace and order and so that seems
to be and I think that's you see this in
in well the sorts of stories that are
influencing even the things that you're
writing like in the Harry Potter series
for example Harry's friends and campaig
treats are quite disciplined Hermione in
particular because she's an absolute
master of her craft but they still break
rules when it's necessary only when it's
necessary and that's what makes them
more than the people who are just
breaking rules all the time the villains
so to speak and also makes them more
than the people that are just being good
by being conformist so you need that
that touch of rebellious nut it's got to
be a flavoring and not the whole diet
absolutely I've actually talked about
that on this podcast before the there's
people in the military that they are
like meta rule-followers these are
people that have been following rules or
whole lives yeah and they've got perfect
grades and they have a team can do these
things and they're gonna make really
good solid leaders like they're gonna be
great leaders yeah but then there's this
like one group above them yeah have that
same thing but they also have that
little bit of rebellion that they'll say
you know what we're not doing that it
doesn't make any sense and that is
really an important factor to have yeah
but you know that's one of the reasons I
like this guy colonel david hackworth
this guy was the
to MIT rule-follower for his whole
career at the end in Vietnam he did an
interview and said if we keep fighting
this way we're not gonna win this war
mm-hmm and they drove him out of the
army mmm but that's that's the thing
that cuz all along the way there was
other times where he do that you know
his guys weren't getting taken care of
he'd break a rule and bring him beer or
he do it you know yeah he'd do that
along the way not not so far outside the
bounds that it would jeopardize his
career because if you would do that then
you're not in charge of these guys
anymore yeah now you're not gonna have
any impact yeah so let's not get fired
right right let's not get stupidly fired
right that's not an improvement exactly
well that's a awesome I guess we I know
you got to go so I can't think that we
could get to a better little krusk of
the little capstone of the conversation
than right there thanks for coming on
again hey my pleasure man I'm glad we
got a chance to talk about this book
this is a book that everybody should
read and and you you I ordered the wall
I ordered a copy of yours with a
foreword yet from Europe yep you can't
buy it from Amazon here you know yet
from Amazon will it boy I don't know
we're still negotiating the rights
because the rights holders differ in
North America and so that's the issue at
the moment Sokka so I worked with an
English publisher penguin in in the UK
that that put out the I think it's
Vantage books if I remember correctly I
should just check and make sure that
that's exactly right
Harper Perennial modern classics that's
not that's not the British one that's
that's not the British one hasn't gotten
to my house yeah and so shit yeah it has
to be ordered it has to be ordered
through Amazon UK and we're working on a
couple of things maybe two also maybe
get the audio rights to the abridged
version because I'd like to read it nice
and that would be good so that people
could listen to it and so because it's
it's an absolutely necessary book yeah
and it's written actually what I like
because it's written very conversational
I mean he's cracking jokes in there he's
making it's a brilliant piece of
literature as well as I mean it's a very
readable book although it's unbelievably
harsh and and and demanding and and
draining to read but it's it's
brilliantly written it's an unbelievably
in gross
read in the most horrible possible way
but and and it is the case that it's
written at this white-hot pace you know
it's like talking to someone who's
righteously not self righteously angry
but righteously angry four four ball
four four four dozens of hours and you
just can't believe the levels of outrage
that are that are being that are being
so incredibly well expressed and so
effectively expressed and and and again
I think it's also worth emphasizing the
fact that you know Solzhenitsyn's real
contribution in many ways was to lay
that catastrophe at the feet of the
doctrine and not to say no this is this
wasn't an aberration because of Stalin
or you know Lenin being the great leader
and then Stalin being the monster
because Lenin was plenty monster himself
and Stalin was the logical conclusion to
Lenin not not an aberration but to say
that no the horrors of what happened in
the Soviet Union were were implicit in
the collectivist system utopian system
that gave rise to the philosophy to
begin with and that that's also an
explanation why the same catastrophes
occurred wherever the Soviet system was
applied everywhere else in the world
it's something we really need to know I
mean we fought a whole Cold War over
that we put damn near put the world to
the torch because of this and the idea
that these ideas are the fact that these
ideas are creeping back is really it's
unbearable as far as I'm concerned so
hopefully people read in this book and
the the re-release of this book with
your ford will prevent that from
happening in a bucket that many other
people can put drops into as well and so
i'm hoping i mean i think the book has
sold 15,000 copies since the beginning
of november which is pretty good for the
reissue an old classic but like it it
it's required reading for an informed
citizen of the 21st century it's not
optional you need to know this material
you're not you're not you don't
understand your position in society as
an individual or a citizen without
knowing this material so it's like not
knowing about what happened
see Germany it's not acceptable to not
know so read the book thanks for coming
George
really good to see again man absolutely
yeah be better appreciate it
and with that Jordan Pederson has
departed the recording studio and if you
noticed that echo Charles was not
present during the recording with Jordan
Peterson but through the miracle of
Technology and recording echo has now
joined us for the support Neil portion
of this podcast so good evening echo
good evening all right so if people
listen to this podcast which we
appreciate and you want to support this
podcast and support yourself there are
ways to do that echo can fill you it
sure so first way is when you're doing
jiu-jitsu because we're all doing
jiu-jitsu yes it might sound a little
bit repetitive but to me when you do
just gonna be doing it every single day
every single week at least even if
you're doing the two times a week three
two I get it either way you're gonna
need a key and a rash guard so there is
no question which kind of gear you get
you get an orange in gay straight up
made in America I watched one of their
videos yesterday and it's kind of an
older one too but it made me like love
origins even more because it's like
you'll see you know the people that make
em and all the ladies there and then
Pete like he has like longer hair and
stuff like that as I called man that's
kind of more of the beginnings of origin
you know anyway I thought it was good
unless again made in America quality
stuff for jiu-jitsu it's not like a
blankie
they get from over wherever some other
place and then slap a embroidered patch
on it
you know say that no this is made for
jiu-jitsu in America yeah everything
made in America from where where we grow
the materialists grown in America woven
in America
woven in Maine as a matter of fact
custom woven by origin we weave it up
there and make the best keys in the
world also got some other stuff for you
know you got t-shirts you can get
sweatshirts and also coming in 2019
jeans yeah
denim origin denim yeah I just call them
jeans though yeah yeah I did yet that
starts to like I don't know move towards
a fashion thing what if you see dent in
denim well I feel oh yeah I guess just
heal that material yeah I feel like it's
like origin denim they make it you know
yeah and then yeah they make origin
jeans for sure but what if they make
like a jean jacket like a jacket no I'd
be true but it'll be a jean jacket
that's true yeah I dig it cool either
way yeah that's too and I don't get
excited for jeans in general in life oh
well yeah like you know you see it on TV
I don't know JCPenney has a sale you
know black fryer whatever and you know
some jeans I don't get excited do you
prime assuming you don't either maybe do
I don't know but when Pete posts little
like videos of the clothes you know
close-up of the buttons the jeans come
on grab that's that's kind of exciting
I'm just saying
either way yeah either way the also we
have supplements to affirmative origin
labs which is expanding yes yeah yeah we
bought another building up there but yes
so they're making we are making
supplements joint warfare krill oil
super krill oil by the way discipline
mmm the Tri vechta yeah yeah the my wife
went on the trip didn't take joint
warfare with her yeah she's there for
3-4 days her knee starts bothering her
it bothers her the rest of the trip she
comes home she goes back on joint
warfare for 3-4 days
nice fine again yeah see that's just
that's just crazy yeah that's just a
reality of it so join warfare good for
your joints krill oil also good for your
joints and good for your good for your
whole life system is that a thing life
system life sis yes okay well yeah it's
good for that
to discipline when you need that focus
and also discipline go yeah which is my
pre cognitive enhancement tool go to go
to yeah yeah yeah yeah it's funny the
krill I had the same situation too by
the way krill oil and joint Warford
didn't bring it yeah by the way in
Hawaii which is the reason why I didn't
appear on this episode of the podcast
you know why so my father-in-law came I
told him the story about how he'd always
talk about krill oil and he's just sort
of looking at me like whatever and you
know he used to tell me oh yeah krill
oil is good good for you all this stuff
and he said not listen cuz you know he's
more of like little health dude yeah and
then when you started talking about it
like literally the day you start talking
I start taking it and he was like he
didn't care it kind of went right over
his head and I was like oh so did you
feel the difference you know like that's
what he was concerned about also on top
of that he's got Moke which is which is
milk basically that's what it is
it's a it has protein in it you mix it
with milk I got a man how to make that
statement if you mix it with well you
can mix it with almond milk you can mix
it with coconut milk you can mix it with
regular cow milk if you mix it with
water it's not I'm not jumping up and
down about it and tell you it's the most
delicious thing in the world if you mix
it with milk whole milk especially I
will tell you it's a it's a it's a
dessert straight-up it's a dessert that
you will make you stronger if so you
know like hot cocoa you ever make oh
yeah okay so I'm a fan that you can put
in water right what do you put in water
in milk mmm that is not hot cocoa to me
okay I know what you're talking about
you eat the little the little packet
that you're supposed to mix with water
it's got the little crappy marshmallows
in it yeah that's not a non-starter for
me yeah so that's kind of the point
there yeah it's sorta that you know
along the same lines where it said cool
do it it's okay you can do it yep and in
there's probably many many many people
who do that and I'm not mad at them but
you put the milk that stuff
that's my thing and by the way you can
have you can't have hot chocolate milk
yeah anything it's good it's right up
there fish it'll work yeah the sir got
mint chocolate peanut butter chocolate
vanilla gorilla and the darkness and
then there's the the warrior kid milk
which has a little bit less protein in
it unless you double up on your scoops
like I do for the strawberry because the
strawberry is ridiculously good so give
that a shot and by the way all these
things are available at origin main calm
and that's that's the state of Maine
yeah yeah not just Maine like the main
spot you know it is the main spot check
cool so yeah also if you want to
represent you know get a discipline
equals freedom shirt or a rash guard you
know get after it any way you want to
represent the path go to Jocko store
calm that's where you can get all this
stuff hoodies
you know hey christmas is coming up
let's face it there's no avoiding it
it's coming up you know so you want to
grab something that's a good place to
grab something some new stuff on there
too but yeah if you want to represent
while on the path jaw closed or calm
good spot also choco white tea so these
claims of deadlifting 8,000 pounds I
haven't deadlift it in a while so I was
like you know what I'm gonna do I'm
gonna test it
mmm Tan's right and he drink it straight
up deadlift deadlift at 8,000 pounds
just like that just like that no warm-up
no you don't need it you know it's real
all the warm-up is drinking some
chocolate yeah when you're warmed up and
you're good 8,000 pound dead left yeah
that's a no this is the only product in
the world in any capacity that
guarantees 100% 8000 pound deadlift
minimum yeah 100%
but yeah so yeah you get them one in the
dry eBags
if that's your thing when you see pop
see that's the word yeah yeah steep
steep okay boom if you like that gig huh
hot cold whatever and then the cans
which I recommend I recommend they can
actually I don't know if I'd recommended
that I
I like them both yeah depending on the
scenario by Mira boom there you go also
subscribe to the podcast on iTunes and
stitcher and Google Play wherever you
listen to podcast there's a lot of new
ones out there there's no apps yeah and
there's a lot of podcasts out there yeah
and listen to a bunch of them yeah yeah
and one of them you can also listen to
in addition to this one if you want you
can check out the warrior kid podcast
that's basically directed at kids but
I'll tell you that uncle Jake has
lessons for everyone in that podcast and
also we got the YouTube channel the
YouTube channel where you can watch this
podcast in its full length and you can
see what people look like if you don't
know what Jordan B Peterson looks like
if you don't know what Eko Charles look
like or if you don't know what I look
like you can watch the the YouTube
channel and you can see all of us if you
never heard if you've never seen echo
before but you've only heard him he
probably doesn't look like what you
think he looks like yeah and I don't
know if that's good or bad enough that's
a backhanded compliment or a backhanded
like derogatory statement about you yeah
your voice probably a little bit of both
yeah but but well suffice it to say that
he's not what you expect when you see
him in reality and he also makes videos
that are enhanced by imagery and music
yeah and those are on there too so you
can check those out you can subscribe to
that YouTube channel also we got the
psychological warfare album and that has
tracks on it of well they're of me
telling you pragmatically why you should
or should not do something like skip a
workout you should not skip a workout
eat donuts you should not eat donuts so
just some little things like that you
can check that out psychological warfare
echo claims that it has 100%
effectiveness
yeah it does should you go to the gym
yes you should and if you listen to the
track you will go to the gym yes 100%
effective and actually I mean a lot of
claims being made about effectiveness on
this yes an area right hey it's real
it's real you know
mm don't align the placebo tested yeah
well you know single blind maybe okay no
that means but and it is official when
okay and I kind of tried to
psychologically and I'll analyze
psychological warfare like why does it
work every single time and here's part
of it even you you know like when you
get hypnotized I'm not saying you're we
should have I should have asked I should
have asked Jordan this question yes do
you agree with this I think okay I think
that goes bro theory so you know like
being hypnotized for example yeah you
I've never been hypnotized yeah me
neither so what but then again it's real
what happens - so have you ever said a
volunteer did not get that okay me
neither same thing so hypnotism from
what I understand is you have to like be
what he call like suggestible open to it
yeah open to it yeah so if you're a
suggestible person that's like you have
a certain kind of mind and then on top
of that even more consciously you have
to volunteer to be hypnotized a guy I
mean I'm sure there's methods that you
can sort of hypnotize someone without
them knowing it or something but usually
even say I'm sure but oh yeah right you
can even there's Owen and then or not
nonetheless usually the hypnotic
sequence goes from hey you volunteer let
conscious yeah sure I'll be hypnotizing
you sit there and you come to 10:00 and
you're closing your eyes and breathing
anyway so you consciously volunteered to
be hypnotized so you're open to being
hypnotized and then blah blah blah so
psychological warfare it's like hey you
recognize okay I have this weakness I'm
about to skip this workout right now
you're basically saying hey I need a
help I need no you know I need a little
spunk volunteering for help well in
Tyrian yeah it's not like I'm like
sitting in my room it's not completely
against your will exactly right
you're not just busting in the door you
know insane hey don't skip the workout
meanwhile in your mind you already
committed to keeping the way it's
different so you're like you're not
committed to keeping the work out you
just like are running the risk of
skipping the work you know that weakness
just creeps in and you're like hey I see
you weakness you're creeping in right
now I'm gonna get I'm basically
I'm gonna tell Jocko that you're in here
and he's gonna you know make you leave
and you play the track or whatever you
have it on your phone right cuz you have
you have all your playlists on your
phone anyway you just play the
psychological warfare one and but you
won't skip the workout soon saying
because you don't want to skip the
workout now no one wants to skip the
work on no one's thinking tomorrow I
can't wait to skip this workout and it's
not like that you know so it's you come
in and you just give that little nudge
that's why it works so good it's true
absolutely true I like it psychological
warfare it's very effective 100% also
while you're working out and if you're
bored with your squats bench get some
kettle bells from on it in my opinion on
it calm /ja good stuff on there
jump rope battle ropes kettlebells clubs
may be careful with the clubs mmm kasha
I was watching a video of a guy doing
this Club routine I was like dang he did
it eat it took a lot of coordination
like I'm looking at it and I was like 40
I think like a big one yeah I can't even
imagine trying to do anything
coordinated yeah with the 40 yes cuz I
only have 220 yeah and yes and they come
off real a lot more heavy than they look
oh yeah like when you grab them I mean
at the end of the day if it's 20 pounds
20 pounds no there's no getting past
that physically but when you pick it up
it's like it's like you know when you
pick up your friend yeah you know or
your kid freaking and they weight 70
pounds it's like Shh I pick up 70 pounds
with one hand it's no problem when it's
a dumbbell should pick up your kid when
there's so many bumps with one hand
can't do it it's hard unless that's how
these clubs are anyway so watch out for
those anyway go to on it calm flash drop
they can get some really cool stuff on
there really cool awesome eh we got some
books as well first off miking the
Dragons I know Jordan and I talked about
it a little bit today and it was
actually sold out for a little bit it is
now back in stock and have many many
many thousands and thousands of copies
that are inbound that are being printed
so if you want Mikey in the Dragons
go to Amazon and order it there's a
little video on there if you want to
know what it's about that echo put
together and it's a it's a solid video
from what I understand the like kids
like to watch the video oh you like it's
like a little mini short it's super fast
is two minutes even in even my kids so
we're in I watched the video if you are
send it to me I watched it like 14 times
elements in it yeah a lot of things
going on yeah to my son it's like a
micro cartoon kinda know it's like a
micro movie yeah I don't know why well
it's a cartoon because there's
illustration illustration yeah but yeah
it's fun we put on the TV when I was in
Hawaii you know you have the Smart TV
and there you can put YouTube on there
oh you thought on there I put on the TV
my kids are all jumping over that mic in
the babies you know it's two minutes
long
yeah no I you know Jordan and I were
talking about it and you know obviously
it's about facing your dragons and
there's obviously a metaphor there and
it's a there's real true pragmatic
simple to understand lessons of how to
stand up and confront the world and
confront your fears that little kids
will clearly and easily understand and
it'll leave an impact on anybody that
reads it
so miking the dragons you can get that
book on top of that if you got kids you
can also get them though the way of the
warrior kid which is another book about
a young kid who's going through the
problems that normal kids have and
luckily his uncle Jake who was a seal
and the SEAL Teams shows up for the
summer and helps him overcome those
problems and then that series carries on
another book called Mark's mission you
can pick those two books up and give him
day whatever kids you those look those
books when you read those books you'll
wish you had that book when you were kid
I know I absolutely wish I had that book
when when I was a kid and I wish I had
that book when my kids were kids yeah
because it teaches them what it is they
need to know period that's it the
discipline equals freedom Field Manual
that book that's how you do that's how
you is it's just a field manual of how
to be on the path of discipline that's
what it is look the path of discipline
is not easy and there's no Field Manual
oh wait there is now but there didn't
used to be there didn't you speak look I
know discipline will help me how do I
get disciplined
where does discipline come from this
none of that information was assembled
anywhere I made a Field Manual for it
it's called the discipline equals
freedom Field Manual it's not it's it's
not like any other book you've ever seen
or read period it's not but it's very
popular it's great if you want there's
another thing critic christmas is coming
this is a christmas scenario right this
is a christmas scenario give this book
to somebody that needs help or needs to
stay on the path or get on the path this
book will be extremely beneficial to
them or people that are on the path
getting after it this will keep them
there so that's the Field Manual if you
want the audio version that it is not an
audible it's on iTunes and Amazon music
and Google Play as an mp3 also the first
book I wrote with my brother Leif babban
it's called extreme ownership but that
is a book taking the leadership lessons
that we learned on the battlefield and
translating them to your business and to
your life and then the follow up to that
book is the dichotomy of leadership
which takes those lessons that we
learned in combat and goes granular in
teaching you how to balance the various
dichotomies that you experience as a
leader so both and all those books are
available on Amazon or wherever else you
might buy books also we got a salon
front which is uh my leadership
consultancy we solve problems through
leadership that's what we do and we work
with companies all over the country and
internationally if you want us to come
and align the leadership at your company
for victory then go to a salon front
calm the we are do we have a Leadership
Conference called the muster and we've
done six musters we are doing three in
2019 we're doing one in Chicago in the
spring we're doing one in Denver in the
fall and we're doing Sydney Australia in
December so if you want to come to one
of those events all the events that
we've done have sold out
all of them these are all absolutely
going to sell out so if you want to come
go to extreme ownership calm and
register and as quick as you can and
then lastly we have EF overwatch we are
connecting Special Operations veterans
and combat aviation veterans that are
looking for work that are proven leaders
that are experienced leaders and we're
connecting them with companies out there
in the civilian sector that need leaders
so if you want to come at that from
either side whether you're a vet or
whether you're a company go to EF
overwatch comm to get in the game and if
you have any more questions for us or
answers for us we are available on the
interwebs on Twitter and on Instagram
and on the face book e echo is adequate
Charles and I am at Jocko willing and I
started out this podcast today pretty
heavy pretty rough and I think it's
important to remember something that I
always refer back to and that is that
evil does exist in the world it's out
there and with that I'd like to thank
all the military personnel throughout
the globe that stand up to evil in the
world and thanks to police and law
enforcement and firefighters and
paramedics and EMTs and correctional
officers and Border Patrol and all the
first responders that stand up and face
evil here at home and to everyone else
out there if things are tough and I know
they get tough life is hard but there's
still reason to be thankful be thankful
you're not in a gulag be thankful that
you're not being tortured be thankful
that you have food to eat be thankful
you have a bed to sleep on and then do
your best to watch out for those little
seeds of evil that
planted around you and planted in you
and keep those seeds of evil in check by
going out into the world and doing good
and until next time this is echo and
Jocko